[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors le plus de ma liste c'est ce sont
les six jeunes qui ont 18 à 24 ans qui
est nous ont rejoints pour faire bouger
les choses
je pense qu'il est essentiel si on veut
construire le voisin de demain est bien
de le construire avec eux mon directeur
de campagne à 21 ans donc j'ai décidé
moi de faire la part belle à la à la
jeunesse un qui me le rend bien
puisqu'ils apportent des idées nouvelles
ils ont une énergie la débordante moi je
suis très fier de cette équipe le plus
c'est vraiment heureux c'est plutôt un
ensemble de mesures cohérentes
mon programme il vise surtout à agir sur
les principaux problèmes que nous que
nous avons un voisin et ce sont des
solutions concrètes et d un grand plan
sur la circulation
c'est aussi des mesures comme une
navette est écrit pour pouvoir déplacer
nos aînés et les personnes à mobilité
réduite
c'est le passeport culture c'est 50
euros pour les jeunes pour qu'ils
puissent pratiquer une activité sportive
ou culturelle surtout en ces instants de
crise sociale je pense que c'est
extrêmement important de préserver
donner du pouvoir d'achat aux 10 6 mois
et puis aussi on aura aussi un revers
d'hier notre notre commune qui est de
plus en plus grise donc on aura un grand
plan sur la végétalisation de dans notre
ville
[Applaudissements]
j'ai deux décisions la première année
symbolique puisque ça fait très
longtemps que je le demande je
baptiserait le bâtiment de la police
municipale arnott beltrame
c'est une c'est quelque chose qui me
porte depuis très longtemps et je n'ai
pas été entendu par malheureusement par
la mairie et la décision politique sera
de me réunir de réunir plus tôt les
maires des villes voisines des maires de
guyancourt montigny et magny les hameaux
avec des représentants de l'agglo du
département de la région pour mettre sur
la table le sujet de la circulation qui
le le sujet pour moi prioritaires dans
ce prochain mandat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]